- We have to understand what
we're good and bad at and you
have to let go of
what you're bad at.
You have to.
If you're naturally bad at
singing like I am you shouldn't
put your career and your
life in a position to become a
professional singer.
It's a bad idea and I think
a lot of people want to be
entrepreneurs and business
people 'cause it sounds
glamorous to make
$1 million a year on
your terms on your own schedule.
The problem is it's a talent.
It is a talent to be a business
person and you can become the
best version of yourself, right,
but it's like being pretty.
Like you can become prettier.
You can get tans,
you can work out,
you know, but mom and dad had
sex at the right moment and your
nose is your nose.
Now, you can have
plastic surgery.
There is no plastic surgery in
business so I need people to
wrap their head around that.
I don't know how to help people
do more of it other than scream
at the top of my lungs about
it for the rest of my life but
anything that can help you get
into a place where you can not
dwell, not complain, not
allow the negativity to seep in,
it will bring you
enormous dividends.
Whether that's a life coach
or a therapist or
a two month retreat to reset or
I don't know
but whatever it is please,
please, please realize
how big of a deal it is.